yeah some friends do bring out the best
in you it's good to invest in those
friendships if you want to upgrade your
network you got to upgrade your network
I'm gonna give you three ways on how to
do it
it's life lesson that I learned for my
parents is you are the five people that
you spend your most time
[Music]
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up belief nation it's seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message invest in good
friendships over to you Bill Gates also
if you want to know what Bill Gates and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my two for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I believe in the
internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that I'm curious about your insight
related to relationships yeah some
friends do bring out the best in you
it's good to invest in those friendships
and you know some friends challenge you
about things you're doing and that you
know that level of intimacy is great I
wouldn't say that I'm you know I was so
obsessed with work I didn't invest I'd
say in my 20s and 30s as much as I
should have
it's really through Melinda and seen you
know other people I realize okay that is
you know it's really worth the
investment to have those people as
you're always there to help them and and
vice versa
you need to have smart colleagues
partners friends mentors around to push
you and challenge you if you are always
the smartest person in the room guess
what you're gonna lose you need to have
the people around you who don't just
tell you that you're a genius who don't
just tell you that you're amazing who
don't just tell you that this is the
best idea ever
but challenge you who kicked you forward
not the people who say you suck you're
never gonna do anything you don't want
those people either but the
who say I like this idea but I think you
need to take it this way or I see what
you're doing but I think you could be
better who challenges you to play a
bigger game who is kicking you forward
not down there's that age-old expression
that you are the result of your five
closest friends it's true now whether
those are actually five people next to
you around you or those fear people you
hang out with and consume information
with online what you feel your head with
is what you become and so if you want to
upgrade your net worth
you got to upgrade your network I'm
gonna give you three ways on how to do
it number one is go to events one of the
things that I found most common with
entrepreneurs is is we're just isolated
you don't know enough people who feel
the same way that you do you don't have
friends or parents who support you they
may say okay go do your thing but they
don't they don't really know what you're
going through they definitely don't know
how to give you advice and one of the
things I really notice from the workshop
that I put on in May in the September
was how many of these people they have
just amazing ideas but nobody around
them is supporting them and finally when
you get in the group there's a magical
thing that can happen when you're around
like-minded people just for one for you
to realize that you're not crazy you're
not the only crazy one who wants to do
something big because in your
environment you might be that only one
person but to be around a group of
people who believe the same things that
you believe who are trying to do crazy
things to and they say I love your idea
just to hear that being around those
like-minded people makes such a huge
difference and so whether it's doing
coming to a workshop like I put on or
just doing an event that's in your city
or traveling to another event being
around like-minded people forcing
yourself to be out of your potentially
negative environment right now at least
the one that's keeping you where you are
and being around people who are doing
big things who are being creative who
are pushing it envelope just like you
want to can make a massive difference
not just for your self-esteem because
you know that it's possible but also for
the motivation as well as for the actual
insights and creativity on what steps
you need to take next and so I highly
encourage you go check out events to get
out of your comfort zone number two is
create a mastermind group I'm in to
mastermind group
I have one that I've created for myself
of local Toronto entrepreneurs we've had
that group for I think coming on 15
years now and once a month we meet and
then once a week you have a call with
the people in the group and you rotate
your partners and I'm also in a weekly
group that is focused just on YouTube
and I'm giving business advice on I'm
taking YouTube advice from the group I
think it's really important to be around
people who are trying to do amazing
things and whether you join a mastermind
group there may not be that many in your
area or you create your own mastermind
group I think it's really important it
could start with just one person you
could just start with one person who you
like who you've hung around who you
share similar ideas but you don't have
consistency you don't have a structure
and so just approaching one person and
saying hey what if we met once a month
to talk about our businesses here's what
I'm doing here's what you're doing and
we'll push each other and we'll just
update each other on what our goals are
and what we're trying to accomplish and
whether it's over coffee over dinner or
at a boardroom or however you want to
structure it doesn't really matter but
making it formalized giving it a
structure instead of when you happen to
have a problem hopefully you call in
that person but somebody who can
challenge you somebody who can give you
new ideas that you're meeting
consistently and then expand my group
the one that I meet locally here in
Toronto has a maximum of 8 people just
because by the time you go around the
table we try to keep our meetings in 3
hours
or shorter and the group that I meet in
my online group every Tuesday is maximum
eight people or six people maximum is
six people and each person goes one at a
time so that person gets half an hour so
I get my half an hour and then in six
weeks I'll get another half an hour and
we try to help each other out so again
there's lots of different or - lots of
different ways to do it the point is if
you find people who you like who bounce
great ideas off of having a formal way -
once a month or once a week connect so
you can help each other out you know
when you are around people again who are
doing amazing things who push you
challenge you give you motivation give
you ideas it can take your business and
your life to the next level so create or
join a mastermind group and number three
or get what I call aspirational Mentors
a lot of people say well I don't have
anything or I'm in a small city and or
everybody around me sucks and there's no
events and there's no masterminds and
all the negativity great aspiration of
mentors
as much as I might talk about events or
mastermind groups I have learned the
most through aspirational mentors these
are people who I've never met who I may
never meet because they past who can
still serve as great role models for you
Bill Gates saved my first company I
never met him I just asked myself who
has built a software company that I can
learn from because I feel like I'm an
idiot I'm trying everything and I'm
still only making 300 bucks a month how
do I grow this thing and by modeling
Bill Gates I was able to grow my company
I've got people in my office here right
like I'm never gonna meet him I'm never
gonna meet him right they passed I got
my parents Howard Schultz Kanye these
people have all learned from but I've
never met well I've met my parents
I bet these guys that's me when I was
nine years old but anybody who you look
up to I would put into two categories
one people who have had success in your
industry whether you like them or not
they've just had success in your
industry and when you can learn to learn
from people who you don't like there's
something about their characteristic or
personality you don't like awesome you
can still learn from them they still
have a strategy that they can teach you
if you take one thing from them you're
still winning I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs but I can still
learn how to be a visionary like him
when you can disassociate yourself to
say well I want to be perfect like that
person there's no one person who's the
perfect everything for you as you're
taking bits and pieces so if somebody
rubs you the wrong way awesome they can
still teach you something so start by
people in your industry like who has
built the 10 biggest companies in your
industry look at their foundation story
look at how they started and what you
can learn from them and then anybody who
just look up to if you're starting
YouTube channel but you love Oprah or
you're starting a shoe company and you
love you know you love APO Giannini the
banker like whoever it is if you love
them they can still teach you something
and you can look at their lessons and
apply to your success as well because
chances are any of these heroes that you
have any these people who look up to
they started with less than what you
already have right now and if they could
do it you can do it too and so part one
is just a motivation knowing that they
came from difficult upbringing and they
won and so you can too and part of it is
also just the actual strategies and
tactics like what did they do to get
from here to here and how can you apply
that to your business so get
aspirational Mentors
now I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna love but before that
question of the day I want
who is your biggest mentor whether
you've met them in real life or their
aspirational mentor who is your biggest
mentor that you have learned the most
from I would love to hear from you leave
it in the comments below
I genuinely like to be friendly with
everyone in the Australian film industry
everyone talks to everyone and if
they're not making fun of you then they
really don't like you
so there's a problem and I also when I
first went to America I noticed there
was an unspoken it's not people tell
stories have don't look this actor in
the eye and all that I've never heard
that before but there is a slightly
unwritten rule of leave the actor alone
let them do their thing it could be our
process it could be because their star
I'm not sure and I always try literally
on the first day to break that down
because I feel self-conscious in that
environment I'd much prefer a grip you
know making fun of me then calling me
mr. Jackman and then not saying nothing
until they say thank you for there's
been great working with you
you know I much prefer to feel we're in
it together the biggest life lesson that
I learned from my parents is you are the
five people that you spend your most
time with so whoever those five people
are that's who you are you know that's a
reflection of you they're good habits
and bad habits will rub off on you and
vice versa
so make sure that the five people that
you spend your most time with is exactly
who you want to be because if you have a
homie and they're like oh yeah like I
really like them but oh man this one
thing they do is like really bad for
them I wish they didn't do it and I wait
I don't ever want to do it it's like you
wanna you want to monitor the amount of
time that you spend with those types of
people because regardless if you know
you might not believe in something that
they're doing regardless that energy is
gonna rub off on you over and over again
and the thinking that they have of why
it's okay that they do it might
eventually rub off on you cuz I can
remember as a parent as my children got
to a certain age and where they look to
me for influence I could remember very
well when I saw the beginning to go to
their friends and that's where their
influence began and that's where their
influence began to increase as a parent
that got a little scary for me because I
could I could see I was having a little
less influence than the friends were
having a little bit more well my parents
were very wise my parents understood
that who my friends were would determine
who I was going to become birds of a
feather flock together and in their
wisdom they decided that they wanted to
know my friends
they wanted to see my friends so
therefore they provided a lot of
wonderful things in our home so we would
have our friends at our house so that my
parents could observe and watch the kind
of kids I ran around with and what I
learned as a kid growing up is very
simple there are some friends that were
positive for me and there were some
friends that were negative for me and my
determination of which friends I was
going to let influence me basically
determine whether I was gonna have a
positive or a negative life fortunately
because of good parental advice and
guidance
I chose good friends which really did
make a difference because you see
friends are wonderful they give us
support they give us strength
they're either though a real asset or
real liability so I would just want to
encourage you choose your friends wisely
you don't need a lot but you need some
good ones if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon if you want more advice
from Bill Gates and other successful
billionaires check out the advice from
Forbes billionaires video that I made
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there when I
started Microsoft I didn't think of it
as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing